Team eyes of Valiant, best of luck.
Take it away.
Alright.
So let's look around this thing and see
what we got.
Yay.
No problem. Got some permissions. Something's not running.
Two two.
Okay. So
so in it container is not ready.
Unless in it container has a very important
name of probe do not delete.
So that special version of cluster to just
for team as a villain must be able
to reach Google before
they can start the clustered application.
Given that we are a network things, you
know, plug in, maybe there is a networking
problem here we need to look at.
That looks good. This is nice. Yeah. Everything's
running.
Yeah. It told us that And have a
Hubble UI.
We have a a UI running. So and
we have Hubble running, so we can use
Hubble. Mhmm.
Yep. Okay.
But if we rewind a bit, so we
had this init container, and it was not
in red state. And I believe it was
doing ping
google.com.
Correct. I'm wondering.
It should use the host resolver.
So even if the core DNS was not
functioning, like, if it was not able to
be Philip, p. Philip So I see here
we've got the rule that allows
anything to reach Kube DNS.
It also has a rule to allow
to star.google.com.
So that should that FQDN lookup should be
allowed.
Your idea is that the init container is
gonna use the host's DNS services.
Correct?
And there you go. That would not be
so how's our pod looking now?
Well, it's running now.
So is this where we're supposed to try
and upgrade it?
Just doing that. Just changing the tag w
two and hopes that that
one reasonable thing to do.
We have an error.
Failed to connect to database.
We definitely saw some policy drops between Postgres
and things.
Yeah. So let's take a look at that
policy.
There we go. Okay. There it is. It
is policy denied. Wait. What?
Cluster talking to a
What what cycles do we service selector here.
It shouldn't redirect to those endpoints. It should
be re redirecting to a different endpoint. That
doesn't seem right.
Do we have Can we take a look
at the service
that this particular
thing is targeting? What service is it trying
to connect to? And let's look at the
service for
is that's the database, Postgres.
Could you
okay. I think okay.
Wait a minute.
Let's look at this. This looks Yeah.
Yeah. Big fan.
Big fuzzy hearts all over the place.
I actually don't think you would find that
one so quickly. So What we're seeing here
yeah. So what we're seeing is that when
and when we do the Hubble Observe, we're
noticing that the clustered application when trying to
communicate with the database
is, for some reason, going to the fluid
d pod.
And we're like, that's weird. Now there is
a function in Cilium that allows you to
do local redirect policies.
So if you were gonna do something like
you had, like, a node local DNS cache,
you know how you can use IP tables
to, like, intercept the DNS traffic and send
it to the node local piece. This is
a mechanism that can also be used for
that, but it's implemented in the EBPF
where where a policy might look like
this.
And that policy is basically saying
that
when traffic within this namespace happens when something
tries to reach the service postgres in the
default namespace
on port five four three two and it's
TCP traffic,
we're gonna redirect that traffic to a different
back end using a local a local endpoint
selector that matches labels app fluent d.
So, basically, in eBPF, we can be like,
don't send it to the postgres database instead
send it to this other thing that is
local inside of this name space.
Should we try the web page, see if
the see if the web page will refresh?
Which one more?
Boop.
Oh. My goodness. They're broken.
Oh, this is going to a.
Does
does the pod have a matching label?
Yeah. That's what looking. Looks That's fair Let's
take a look at the policy real quick.
Got
CMP
clustered.
That's what we got.
Reading this,
I'm looking for
app app postgres and app clusters. So if
I did kubectl.
Or you could just do get pods to
show labels and see what User actually. All
the labels. See what they actually did call
it. Oh. It's postgres q l. They got
all fancy. Yeah. You've guessed it before it
even happened. Well done.
Can we just rather check again?
Well done.